les bouchers charcutiers vont bien merci
pour eux la journée qui leur était
consacrée aujourd'hui à la foire
européenne tend à le prouver
les maîtres de l'art n'avait il est vrai
pas lésiné sur les moyens en proposant
une carte qui séduirait les gourmets les
plus difficiles didier givaudan clodagh
pour les bouchers charcutiers la foire
de strasbourg est l'occasion d'exposer
les techniques de fabrication des
spécialités gastronomiques une opération
aux fourneaux ouvert en quelque sorte
c'est aussi un moment privilégié pour
vanter les deux atouts la corporation
qualité des produits et traditions des
recettes une corporation qui résistent
sont toutes assez bien la concurrence
des grandes surfaces
la meilleure preuve étant la stabilité
du nombre de boucher charcutier
mais la foi c'est aussi une exposition
des plus belles pièces confectionnées
par des commerçants l'exercice des
candidats au titre de compagnon ou au
brevet de maîtrise les spécialistes donc
qui rivalise d'habileté et d'originalité
dans le choix des produits et la de les
présenter
la foire constitue donc une vitrine
idéale pour les élèves des lycées
professionnels
les bouchers charcutiers de demain pour
utiliser au maximum les outils du
boucher un pas prudent l'emporté pièce
vous serez mieux notés si vous prenez
une photo et le cannet votre carottes
après vous avez oublié de la langue des
collègues du cornichon en taille et de
l'autre côté vous avez des roses père
exigeant mon cru et le reste du plateau
trouver de la charcuterie d' ici en
déguste avec les yeux et non le palais
étape durant classement est donc
éminemment difficile
tous ces plats sont remarquables il nous
donne l'eau à la bouche mais sur quels
critères les départager vous il ya
plusieurs critères qui entrent en ligne
de compte bien sûr il ya des travaux la
présentation d'ensemble de tous ses
plats il ya également le choix des
matières premières la qualité des
matières premières on tient compte
ensuite du décor de la garniture de ces
différents plats et bien sûr delà de la
vue d'ensemble que donne tout cet
amalgame de ces différents
critères alors sur se classe en
particulier ici bon ce qu'il faut
souligner ici c'est un travail
extraordinaire qui a demandé beaucoup
d'heures certainement mais il ya quand
même quelques toutes petites fautes
techniques
1 par exemple l'enrobage des galantine
qu'est ce qu'on pourrait encore dire il
ya peut-être la finition de certaines
des galantine qui n'est pas tout à fait
comme elle devrait être parfait dans
l'ensemble on peut quand même dire que
c'est un très très beau cas du très bon
travail qui seraient exposés dans les
vitrines des commerçants en lice avant
d'être dégustés par quelques fins
gourmets